and ted it is just bone dry so hot i
mean this is another what
seven days of this heat wave and we
could break some records yeah uh we
broke a record today
and more on the way unfortunately we
knew that was going to happen we warned
you about it last week live look outside
behind me here
showing some clouds but no storms here
hopefully that changes next week
as those temperatures will drop yes they
will drop next week thankfully
the all-time high for las vegas hottest
temperature on record is 117 degrees we
reached that four times
last time was back in 2017. we could
reach that
or maybe even beat that this weekend i'm
going to show you those numbers
in just a bit so you send it off on
social media when we showed you those
numbers and here's what you had to say
wayne webster says fall can't get here
fast enough
we agree with you rosemary donato says
not funny ted
that's how i think she said it not funny
ted all right
well carrie denton says every everyone
stay safe and cool yes we agree with you
carrie everyone needs to stay safe and
cool the hottest part of the day of
course between
two o'clock and six o'clock be indoors
watch channel eight 112 in centennial
hill it's 105 and similar right now 110
for the lakes 109 for aleante so numbers
have dropped a little bit
but still remain elevated and hot
downtown 115 113 sunrise manor
green valley 112 same for henderson
southern highlands here at 117 rhodes
ranch
at 110 outside the valley 110 also for
prompt death valley 119
110 for boulder city and 113 for
laughlin
wait and see the overnight lows for
death valley that's coming up just a bit
radar network does show some activity a
little bit of moisture
underneath that high mainly in mohave
county and this was really mainly dry
thunderstorms yes there was rain with it
but lightning strikes still detected
there north of i-40 east of kingman
probably getting some
good gusty winds out there in kingman
there's the high right now so even
though it
did meander its way towards the east
most of the moisture stayed off
towards the east and look at all this
wrapping around that high if this high
was over here
right in the middle of four corners that
could pull up some moisture our way but
that wasn't the case for the day today
so here's our heat risk
and we're collaborating with the
national weather service to give you
guys a good warning of what to expect so
heat illnesses will remain high i like
to put the pets remember pets need to be
in here burn paws that's going to remain
high too
so make sure you feel the pavement with
the palm the meat of your hand
before you take them out for the walk do
it nightfall all right
morning relief and mountain relief will
we get any relief in those times not
going to happen
just moderately because we have heat
advisories in the mountain
and your morning temperatures will still
be in the 90s the latest on elsa here's
what's amazing me
is elsa is still a tropical storm when
it's over land it doesn't give it any
strength anymore it usually dies out
but that it will still be a tropical
storm as it makes its way through the
delmarva
the cape nantucket there maybe maintain
its strength as a
tropical system as it moved its way into
canada there 91 overnight
extra warm overnight possible record
warm low record high for tomorrow for
sure 115 or high for
tomorrow your 8 day forecast shows the
heat will continue through monday
slightly cooler next week i'll take that
106. brian over to you
ted